voici djeric automne c'était il y a
trois ans lors d'une conférence obama ou
ici en train de vanter les mérites de sa
plateforme kadri gars qui permet
d'investir dans les cryptes aux monnaies
comme les bitcoins des clients comme ce
jeune homme de vancouver qui préfère
rester anonyme
certains ont confié jusqu'à 70 millions
à qadri gars est aujourd'hui
l'entreprise ne retrouve plus l'argent
il faut comprendre qu'il ya deux types
de gestion des crises au manège en
allemagne ce qu'on appelle les rats
toilettes ou les portefeuilles show en
français qui est liquide ch'ti de tous
les jours en plus on peut faire
comparation après un guichet automatique
ont pas l'option retire de l'argent on
en est immédiatement c'est pas
l'entièreté de l'argent circulation qui
dans les guichets un gros grosse partie
de cet argent alors est dans ce qu'on
appelle le contrôle de l'entreposage à
froid qui va lille coffret de sûreté et
ce coffret de sécurité
c'est jerry cotone qui avait accès et
lui seul problème il est allé en inde à
la fin de l'automne dernier parce qu'il
avait financé un orphelinat pour
l'organisme enjoy house on peut
effectivement trouver sur internet cette
photo d'un bâtiment avec son nom sur une
banderole
mais le 9 décembre à l'âge de 30 ans
jericho tonnes meurt des suites de la
maladie de crohn une inflammations de
l'intestin un certificat de décès établi
au rajasthan
un testament rédigé deux semaines avant
selon le globe and mail
cinq bonnes manières de faire une grosse
faute d'argent puis ans disparaissait
mystérieusement à mourad même très très
loin puis en prenant les arrangements au
préalable pour partir avec les filles de
la voûte littéralement donc à ce que
c'est possible c'est possible mais les
législateurs sont dépassés par les
événements les gens ont beaucoup discuté
à comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
que tout le monde est donc vraiment ses
points forts drôles c'est encore le
moment de deux prêtres de profiter du
système totalement dans les
portefeuilles
il ya 180 millions de dollars et
l'entreprise doit également 70 millions
en devises pour éviter les procès un
juge de halifax où habitait djeric
automne a donné 30 jours de sursis à
qadri gars pour essayer de retrouver le
mot de passe qui valait 180 millions il
si matthew prost radio canada montréal